[Música]
que sea yo que tenga que dar una idea
inspiradora de mí me aterra bastante
pero bueno la verdad es que estoy muy
agradecido por esta aquí porque este es
un hito muy importante en mi vida yo
siempre he querido dar una charla ted y
nunca supe cómo se podría dar una de
ellas pero la verdad es que que me hayan
invitado me parece fantástico
no sé si yo invitaría a alguien de mi
perfil a dar una charla ted pero bueno
ya que estamos aquí a mí me gustaría
reflexionar sobre aspectos vitales una
de las cosas que más me inspiran a mí es
sentarme a tomar café yo solo y quedarme
un poco a mi aire un poco abstraído de
la realidad y él llegaba a comprobar que
hay una estadística clara de las cosas
que suelen pasar cuando uno toma café
que es que se queda un poco aturdido
mirando al cielo y empieza a escuchar
voces voces y voces
y el nexo común de todas las voces
sabéis cuáles es la crítica la crítica
todo el mundo se dedica a criticar al
otro y además en voz alta sin ningún
problema tú estás allí sentado tomando
café y es que mi jefe es un paquete es
que este yo daría mejores que vaya a un
gordo buena fe allá que tú no entiendes
por qué todo el mundo tiene que estar
criticando y eso es una cosa que nos
tiene que llevar a la reflexión cada vez
que nos critican nos ponemos súper
tristes súper tristes siempre que
estamos en nuestro presente cuando hay
quien nos ataca realmente nos hundimos y
nunca nos paramos a pensar
que hemos hecho hasta el día de hoy para
merecer lo que tenemos no yo creo que si
sois capaces de transformar la crítica
en algo positivo os vais a volver en
algo que se convierte en anti frágil
porque porque será mucho más difícil que
os acaben rompiendo si sois capaces de
tener las herramientas para volveros aún
más positivos pues van a criticar por
todo cuántas veces hemos oído por ahí
que es que lo que estudia es una [ __ ]
esto ya es una [ __ ] pero si por
ejemplo juntamos todos los años que
habéis estado estudiando una media
vosotros que estáis por aquí digamos que
había estudiado poco unos siete años
pues en este tiempo unas 25 mil 500
horas os habría dado tiempo a leer 300
libros entonces si vosotros pensáis que
alguien que se han ido 300 libros es un
ignorante pues tiene quizá tengáis un
problema pero no sólo eso si el tiempo
que invertí 6 en vuestros estudios lo
veréis dedicado a caminar y caminar y
caminar habíais dado casi siete vueltas
al mundo el tiempo que invertiste y pse
en vuestra formación tan criticada y por
la que vosotros pensáis que no vales
para nada os hubiera dado tiempo a tener
un montón de experiencias vitales pero
claro salir de vuestros estudios y la
gente dice que no tiene idea de hacer
nada nunca ha hecho nada es un paquete
fenomenal otra historia cualquiera de
vosotros y desde aquí ha trabajado vamos
a poner un tiempo medio de trabajo pues
unos 15 años
y 15 años nos ha pasado un montón de
cosas en el aspecto laboral vamos a
pasarlo en una media imaginaos de una
experiencia semanal en una experiencia
semana la cual le hemos invertido pues
unas 8 horas no todos sabemos que
trabajamos 40 horas pero yo lo voy a
centrar en que cada semana cada semana
desde que tomar una decisión y la había
reflexionado ocho horas a la a la
historieta
no sé si os gusta la música habría sido
a dos mil conciertos dos mil billeteros
conciertos o sea deberíais decirle a
alguien que ha estado en 2000 conciertos
que no tiene ni idea de música no quién
será el ignorante en ese caso sería yo
serían ellos 2000 conciertos quien de
aquí hasta en 2000 conciertos ninguno de
vosotros dudaría el tema de los 300
libros pero y 22 mil conciertos esto es
prácticamente imposible alguien que
hasta en dos mil conciertos sabe de
música hoy en día está más de moda de
estar en 2000 restaurantes y decir que
sabes de cocina pero bueno esos
problemas que tendríamos que empezar a
pensar no no pero ya más
profundamente diréis que he hecho yo en
la vida
pues yo por ejemplo os haría pensar aquí
hay gente joven gente más madura más
senior en los últimos
pongamos que 30 años
si por ejemplo yo creo que este fin de
semana con 50 personas fin de semana 50
personas no está mal no
si hubieras perdido cinco personas a la
semana
hoy vuestros amigos estarían en una
cancha de baloncesto de unas ocho mil
diez mil personas
y claro alguien que se junta con 10.000
personas yo creo que ha tenido un montón
de experiencia y conocimiento diez mil
personas
sabéis que si gastar es una obra de
vuestro tiempo en actualizar cómo le ha
ido la vida a esas 10.000 personas
tardaría tres años pensáis que alguien
que se dedique intercambiar intensamente
experiencias durante tres años sin parar
con gente diferente no tiene nada que
decir
pues este es el problema muy poca gente
tiene el derecho a criticarlos
muy poca gente tendrá el derecho de
haceros daño pero si os hace es fuerte
en la crítica y lo convertirse como en
alguien positivo esto os será mucho más
fuertes por lo tanto yo os digo una cosa
cuando vayáis a criticar a alguien por
su aspecto
pensar
sí
mosley stage los 300 libros
si fuiste jce
a los 2000 conciertos
si disteis las siete vueltas al mundo y
sobre todo
si tendríais diez mil amigos que no
fueran el facebook
[Aplausos]